ask you before you go in F on that did
you do you recall did you ever make a
statement like that yesterday that maybe
somebody you were messing around and
somebody said they saw it or heard it
they ain't never SE heard nothing okay
can I see your
backpack you have anything else on you
that you shouldn't have on you today
could you empty your pockets out for
me mycket huh mycket for what cuz I'm
checking for the S I thought you were
searching my I'm checking everything
there nothing then empty your pockets I
don't huh I don't feel like empty your
pocket so you're going to be put l uh I
smell weed but that I I I'm listen I'm
just explain it to you that I'm doing a
safety check no one's accused you of
anything but why search we
though we have a serious allegation so
we are going to search you okay but can
you call my mom cuz I don't feel this is
necessary it was kids in the classroom I
know stand up stand up what wait why cuz
I'm telling you to stand up stand
up yeah you're not under arrest you
understand that okay okay miss him no
sir I don't feel this is necessary to
sech me
though get I can't hear you H you got to
what I I got use the back okay well okay
probably some
shake down on the bottom of this that's
pencils bro okay don't be upset with me
I'm not upet with you but why are yall
searching me I told you why oh my
godour 22 you got nothing on I'm going
to step out for a second St I'm going to
step out
okay come
on come on oh my God you my
off son of a
that's my
wallet just goad tell them signal zero
where Y
Yankee a
nothing the search oh my God is this
necessary yes ma'am
yes I don't have nothing
else I don't just cooperate bro I am
cooperating oh my God bro you
serious sit down how did it
come I'm going step out back with Mr
just for a second I didn't harm
nobody you you're in possession of a
firearm on understand that I understand
that but no one was was received it
doesn't matter if anybody's
harmed you're not allowed to possess a
firearm period let alone on full
ground okay I'm gonna read to you your
Miranda okay okay you have the right to
remain silent anything you say can huh
am I going with jail okay right now you
can Min okay you have the right to
remain silent okay anything you say
Canon will be used against you in a
court of law you have the right to talk
to a lawyer and have your lawyer present
with you while you are being questioned
if you cannot afford to hire a lawyer
one will be appointed to represent you
before questioning if you decide to
answer questions now without a lawyer
present you still have the right to stop
answering at any time and speak with a
lawyer you may use any of these rights
at any time during the interview do you
understand the rights that I just read
to you yes
okay you want to answer questions yes
okay what are you doing with a handgun
on school crowns no I honestly was not
trying to harm anybody with I was just
carrying it around that's it why were
you carrying it around on school grounds
because I understand that it's people on
school ground that likes to bully people
and I felt like I I was being bullied by
certain people on school ground okay
chamber where did you get the gun I got
it from off the
street did you steal it from no ma' did
you acquire it from somebody else so how
did you get
it yes how long have you had the gun
how many times have you brought it to
school just like the
firsted first yes I swear yesterday I
didn't bring no gun yesterday I swear
okay I heard a statement that you
brought Kelch 380 semi-automatic is
there anything in it yes it's loaded
it's loaded I'm sorry no it's not
a this it's a Ruger not a keltech it
looks just like a kelte
Sean
Lo it was it has a magazine with bullets
and there was one in the chamber it's
going to be a transport right yes sir oh
yeah I'm just can I can I make a phone
call you can make a phone call when you
get to the in County Jail the county
jail yes are you serious yes I'm going
to talk to you because I'm your
administrator I'm I'm like your parent
today here's what I want to tell you why
they you have something from so it's
very serious nature so they're going to
they're going to have to do this until
it gets worked out are you serious bro
no one was though you're walking around
in school with a gun with bullets in it
understand it but no one was harm sir I
don't care it is a felony to have a
weapon on school
grounds plus you were a juvenile or did
you turn 18 I'm 18 you're 18
now okay so you're going to the county
jail okay you serious yes I can't even
call can you call my mom for me we will
call her well you could call her from
the jail oh man
she's I was I was just going to get off
juvenile
probation it's this one time thing I
never bought it yesterday I swear I
never bought it yesterday you may not
have I just we just got a CHP and I told
you when I got you out of the classroom
I have to look at all tips whether it's
weapons guns whatever is weed I didn't
bring no weed okay well it smell of it
that's all yeah and uh but when we asked
to empty your pockets you you know if
you refuse this is what
happens so if I would empty my pockets I
would never did this no we well you
still would have been arrested but you
don't have to go through all the anguish
just you know that when you're in my
office with deputies and you know you
have something it's best just it's not
going to get any better I want to know I
just want to know was going so just like
I told you you're going to go to the
county jail okay you're under arrest
right now for possession of a weapon on
school grounds it's a
felony okay so you will we're getting a
transport unit here you're going to be
transported to the county
jail okay at that time you will be able
to use the phone in Booking yeah Mr
Branch to call whoever you'd like good
what's up just call it for me no
ma'am
yeah
who do you live with just curious I
still with my mom your mother yeah does
she know you got one
no I mean you're 18 she's
18 I think we'll eventually on my end
contact your mother I don't can you
please I she knows please well that's
the law enforcement right now she will
know when you contact at the jail yeah
you're in control right now right now
you are 18 okay you're an adult at this
point so we don't have to follow the
same things that we live with a
juvenile okay so when you get to the
county jail you can call Mom you're
going to have to wait yeah it's in her
bag it's in her bag earbuds are in her
bag this is in her bag it's a lip boss I
think what about your jacket do you want
to keep that on or
you do you have any other jewelry on no
what about your belt
yeah ficia are you in fear of anything
no I'm
just is there anybody at school that
you're worried about I mean yeah it was
not any longer I don't I don't
know um my Apple watch please um kids
was trying to like they was messing with
me and my sister and I did you record it
to anybody yet yes my sister record PL
of
time we came Miss vote about it plenty
time it was um a couple of girls but
okay well we'll get right now we just
want to make sure that we're doing
everything that we can and and now were
you worried that the these girls were
going to attack you with weapons yeah
they always seeing how they going
through